greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by zip recruiter how hiring is
challenging but there's one place you
can go to hi we're hiring is nice and
simple fastest mud a place with grown
businesses connect to qualified
candidates this place is called zip
recruiter com zip recruiter sends you a
job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there
zip recruit is so effective that 80% of
a tipsy employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through to the site within the first day
you heard that right now right now the
church family can try zip recruiter
listen to me I don't care how big less
more your businesses you can try the
prakruti for free for free that's right
free and this is exclusive address zip
recruited com slash Church I don't care
how big your business is you want the
right person
zip recruit will deliver the goods go to
zip recruited comm slash Church CH you
are CH that zip recruiter that coms last
Church the podcast is also brought to
you by on it supplements weights
kettlebells clubs weighted vest they got
it all me I can only save you 10% other
supplements and you know me always
tip-top Magoo because of the island
alpha brain always on thought always
focused ready to [ __ ] rock and roll
understand me so go to on it comrade now
take a look at the great selection of
supplements read do some [ __ ] reading
do some research and then get back to me
but right now what I'm gonna do is they
got on it alpha brain or the percent
money-back guarantee if you don't like
it and you keep the product who gives a
[ __ ] take a chance Columbus did you got
the shrimp export and the shrimp tech
immune which I live off I'm just
starting to get ready to fly I'm back on
the [ __ ] amine why because there's
germs out there and there's people don't
give a [ __ ] but anyway don't get me
fried up so early in the [ __ ] morning
go to alikom slash Church and get 10%
off delivered right to your
[ __ ] house it's Valentine's Day
kick this muley happy Valentine's Day
whatever your situation is you know you
could be down
be excited that your boyfriend's taking
you to Benihana are you taking that
little brought out tonight he's gonna
give her this time ain't gift for the
first time you've been working it's it's
after Christmas whatever your situation
I've been in both situations where I had
I had horrible Valentine today by
yourself for the Chinese joint make him
believe it don't hurt but it hurts
nobody wants to talk to young Valentine
not even a chubby chick you know I'm
saying if you got problems that's is it
your breath is it your head do but on
the other hand listen if they're meant
to be they're meant to be they're the
worst [ __ ] thanks happy thanks
whatever the [ __ ] Valentine's Day
Valentine's Day ever had was 1984 this
you know the year oh yeah I got it
written down don't ever go back there
like 85 can see Valentine's Day is five
days away from my birthday oh yeah so
it's all connected so we're didn't
either kicks off the birthday week or
your mind goes in the pizza old and
you're depressed on your birthday too
because you didn't get a little [ __ ]
finger banging in on Valentine's Day you
know I'm saying you didn't bring enough
flowers so whatever the [ __ ] you did but
it'll give us a [ __ ] I'm just trying to
tell you it's not that bad
eventually you'll find your Valentine
and you'll sail off into the front world
the world of love [ __ ] love and it all
works out to you guys this week
something really will happen last week
that uh sometimes years ago when I was
trying to get joint custody of my
daughter they did it I had you know
because my wife wanted to break my balls
like no legal system to stall my wife
ordered a bad battery of tests like that
you go and talk to her site can all this
[ __ ] and take a written examination and
they try to [ __ ] with you whatever I
went down there you know I wanted to be
a dad so I went down and took the test
and they came back that uh I had not
that much out but they were like the
[ __ ] time you know I have gone to
prison I came out I was trying to get on
my feet I [ __ ] worked 80 hours a week
hard with your hands guys roof and
hustling getting cars and Here I am
[ __ ] broke up to debt with credit
cards this chick don't want to give you
a kid you do get mad at the [ __ ]
world I mean you have every right to be
mad especially when your
[ __ ] up to boot and the whole thing
and I was really aggravated and I what
the [ __ ] we talking about the testing
and they said I had no [ __ ] empathy
and I bow as a comic at the time I wrote
a joke about it you know I got no
empathy who gives a [ __ ] but then it was
[ __ ] like I'm like this is a
[ __ ] thing because I really it
really bothered me there hasn't been a
lot of things that bother me like I had
to have to test but this one got to me a
little bit because Hannibal what the
[ __ ] are you from talking to me you know
what I'm going through you have no
[ __ ] idea what I was going through at
the time the only thing that was keeping
me afloat was the [ __ ] stand up that
was what was keeping me afloat so I this
last week you know I'm trying to do this
thing with Fox and the whole thing and
I'm meeting with these riders and I
looked down and I had two missed calls
and that night I went home and this is
why I tell people always to pick up the
[ __ ] phone always pick up the phone
you know I didn't have the phone in my
pocket it was in my bag
and when I went to my notebook I had the
two missed calls and I got in the car
and I had a shoot to pick up mercy and
the day one behind me that night I went
on Facebook and one of the kids had
called me I posted that his mother died
and my [ __ ] heart dropped
I mean my heart drop I know why he
called me and I felt [ __ ] really
shitty and I put up a post on Facebook
and this kid there's not a lot of sweet
sweet hearted kids in this place trust
me
Lee's one of them that's very very sweet
hearted and this kids another and his
name is Jerry
Rogerio choose one of the five cast
multiple time and he's a dear dear dear
friend of mine I ought to tell you some
guys all these people you see on Comedy
Central and all these plans I'm like
listen man they're their own
personalities or whatever but there's
these kids that are here there's certain
types of kids that are here they got
into the comedy game and their heart is
gold and when you if you know anything
about
life when something shitty happens to
them you say to yourself Jesus there's
people like me walking around did shitty
stuff and why would something like this
happen to a kid like this is mom passed
in the middle of night in her sleep she
just passed and I called him the next
day early and we spoke and I let him
vent is it's all about renting at that
point you're in the [ __ ] fog you
don't even know if this is real you're
checking around with people to see if
vestal talking to you you know this
could be a dream so I spoke to him I
talked him off the ledge a little bit
and then we spoke that at that evening
again and his mom was getting a berry
that uh Joe Jackson funeral Paula Joe
Jackson funeral parlor something and I
saw that in the middle of night and I
picked up the phone beeping the
ballbuster that I am because he's
Mexican and I got the phone like you
know like hello Joey like he's half
sentimental I think oh not for nothing
Jerry I got listen your mom's dead she's
gonna wake up in a funeral policies and
see a picture Joe Jackson on the wall
she's a Mexican woman you gotta get her
I could he broke down into tears I'll
make the last thing a Mexican woman
wants to be surrounded by the Jackson 5
trust me when I'm telling you and we
were [ __ ] dying and that's what you
do to somebody whose mother just died
because if you're gonna hit him you get
better in tomorrow okay and I woke him
up out of a cold sleep that was even
worse that's a type of mother [ __ ] I am
just to let you know that I know what
you're going through and I had that as
soon as my mother died you know it takes
the people around me that's who I knew
who my friends were because they took
that time to make a call to me and break
my balls like the Caesar and I'm like
you [ __ ] dozy your friends I
still my mother's it was Joe Jackson I
don't make secure the late Joe Jack look
I don't know I just saying it was just a
joke that maybe his mother was racist I
don't know you know how Mexicans are
they call them my I phase or something
so I'm just listening
your mom you think your mom wants to be
surrounded by the Jackson 5 you think
the last thing in my
one sees a picture Joe Jackson on the
wall just tossed it out and we bought
and then we started crying I started
crying from you know and and we sent a
thing down to Joe Jackson funeral parlor
and you know he called me Sunday and we
spoke and we tried to get together and
he came to the store last night and we
spoke and it was just great and when
somebody bombs I've been there I've
walked down that [ __ ] Street and I
knew how I would anybody listen with
anybody post on Facebook that they lost
anybody I always tried to say something
I don't know them well enough I know you
on Facebook I know you follow the church
and I won't I'll just say sorry for your
loss and I'll think about you and you
know and I've had a lot of friends from
Facebook but I've lost people and I
understand from Bob La Manga Studio
friend that I can't forget his name and
he lost his son on Facebook Chad Rosen
her just rose and Kirk [ __ ] great guy
Canadian dude right yeah yeah you know
we've been through this is that one I
don't know him but I've suffered for
them I get where the [ __ ] their heads at
you know so uh it was just funny that I
was you know it's my [ __ ] this will
be I was trying to explain to Jerry last
night at the Comedy Store as soul as I
can be but as honest as I can be the
same way as I can honestly be with you
guys that this next birthday is the 40th
birthday have had without my mother and
I can't tell you that I missed those
birthdays with it if you want me to lie
to you and tell you I I did last night
at the table thinking about meeting
Jerry I'm sitting there staring at my
dinner my wife was in the kitchen my
daughter was across from me she's
[ __ ] you know playing with a super
ball so she doesn't see me go into a
haze last night I went into a haze for
my two minutes like that
like a mental flashback when you see on
television I actually lived through one
last night because I had to meet Jerry
Jerry says he was gonna go at dinner and
stop by the store I don't mind Jesus
Christ I can't believe I'm turning 56
next week I'm like wait a second
that's the 40th birthday without my
mother
l had you sat there for a few minutes
and I thought the stain come up and I
restrained myself a little bit but still
I was still drawn to emotions and I
still got tears in my eyes and I still
remember that [ __ ] last birthday like
if the universe sends you signals I
should have read them
because it was the first birthday that
we had celebrated without the bar and
that was her baby that was her whole
[ __ ] life we always she always and
don't get me wrong the parties were
grandioso till I was about ten or eleven
that I wanted to cut down on it might
even like big parties no more so we just
kept him to like the inner circle at the
bar a couple of drunks a couple bookies
would come some of their kids but that
was the first birthday I didn't
celebrate at the bar so woman when I
woke up that morning the feeling in the
house was a little down not on my end at
that I already had the day planned out I
had already my birthday planned that for
the longest [ __ ] time for my 16th
birthday I had a karate competition in
Jersey City I was still going to karate
over and [ __ ] 27th and 22nd in
central with that dude and I was going
on karate tournament my plan was to take
first in the forum and take first and
finally get the trophies go home and
quit karate never go back like that was
it I was done with karate I played
freshman basketball and I didn't start
that that was wearing thin on my soul
like I put all this work into something
and I thought I was on the start and it
was a complete opposite I barely [ __ ]
played my freshman year I didn't know
where I stood in basketball and guess
what I didn't want to take a bus to
karate no more you know I was hanging
out with a new
kids around my neighborhood and I made
the worst move I haven't made in my life
was to quit karate at that age because
at least Diana a schedule I always had
to answer this his name was Kevin
Norland I hope he's still alive I heard
he's still alive and I always had an
answer to him he was a tough [ __ ]
karate teacher there was no smile on his
face
there was no joking around in class
there was nothing there was nothing this
guy had zero emotion and if you didn't
do what he [ __ ] told you he just
[ __ ] kicked you well there's no
Vietnam orange Asian foot cuz he was a
Vietnam vet and he stayed over there and
staying in karate ville and living
karate for two or three years til he
brought it back to the states so he was
using this combo karate tactic of
fighting we became savages in the
tournament scene and we were good at
high kicks and then we had trick kicks
and he just trained us to be [ __ ]
savages I mean you had a sweep you know
if you if you didn't get certain grades
on your report card he would put you in
the corner and make you do homework and
making jumping jacks and [ __ ] I mean
this guy was a no-nonsense karate
program like there was no [ __ ] belts
you had to go to competitions to get
belts there wasn't no it wasn't like
every 90 days you test and they charge
you 35 hours and they promote your no no
no no no no this guy was like jujitsu we
gave you about when you thought you were
ready there was no guidelines so all the
other schools around the area after you
were there for a time period you
automatically got a belt and tested not
this guy to get a strike yet like throw
somebody to a plate-glass window like he
was like the dude from karate but it
wasn't he and he had a class of savages
and I had already been with him for four
years five years I had to take a bus
there and walk [ __ ] nine blocks it
was just too much on me at that time I
wanted to be into girls
and I wanted to hang out with the
[ __ ] guys in my neighborhood so my
plan was to wake up on my birthday
morning and go down to Jersey City go to
this [ __ ] high school do the karate
tournament
back on the bus and meet my friend to
smoke dope and drink [ __ ] beer I wake
up that morning my mom makes me
breakfast she apologizes for not the
bond I tell us and there's no big
[ __ ] deal I got my day planned I
didn't want to have a party anyway I
[ __ ] hated those things after a while
and now I look back and I wish he would
have lived I would have still had him
every [ __ ] year because I won it was
my birthday I know what it was meant to
hurt like it wasn't even about me she
had such shitty birthdays as a kid that
she celebrated the whole week I saw Tom
papa this toilets right and we were
talking about New York except City when
I was growing up how every year on my
birthday I went to the Harlem
Globetrotters and we're gonna be in town
because every Monday when I grew up
every every year my birthday is on the
19 so that means that my birthday always
fell on Monday Sunday or Tuesday for
some reason it was close to that area
you know I live it feels different when
you're a kid so every Monday is presents
thing when we were growing up you off
Lincoln's birthday on the 12th and you
off the 19th you these [ __ ] cut
it down to one holiday these [ __ ]
come back but then they gave you money
look the king zora balance is that so
but it used to be two mondays in a row
you were off in the old days so my
mother would start that party the Monday
before she would start our own personal
party which the drinking and the [ __ ]
it's not like it's Coco's birthday this
week it was like she was more excited
than I was I was excited for the
presents and for the party and the food
my mom used to make these little [ __ ]
ham sandwiches called bocalee toast oh
my god and she cut the [ __ ] they cut
the sides off and they make thousands of
the [ __ ] planet if you look at that
picture of me as a kid dancing and you
look at the table there's a picture of
mojitos on the [ __ ] table it's like
this deviled ham spread with Spanish
style with olives ooh [ __ ] oh and then
cut the edges off the bread that some
white bread was different all we I would
eat a thousand of those things but she
would only make them on my birthday oh
that was part of the deal only on my
birthday
so she promised me to make me a couple
book I'll eat those and I was I went
that did something with my friends and I
went and got my game when I came back
told my mother's Bunny's right the house
I'm not oh and I Homer no they were
brothers they're all like brothers but
they were bookies great guys I I adored
them growing up and they were just gonna
have beers at the house and then watch a
little something then we're gonna watch
something or whatever and then they were
gonna go to a track that was with my
mother and our Nardo and that crew did
everyday they went to attract but there
was a hit there was a hitch like [ __ ]
18 inches of snow fell so we didn't
think there was gonna be a karate
tournament oh they didn't give a [ __ ]
the twin of it went on and we had to get
down there so we had to walk up the
[ __ ] hills get her number one bus
with chains on in those days the buses
kid rock candy Boulevard
it was [ __ ] the day from hell but
before I left
Arenado said hey man I forgot to get you
a birthday present he was a book he goes
what do you want for your birthday
he goes I got ten bucks you want me to
put on a number for you and I go yeah
and he goes what numbers I got to
nineteen just put it on [ __ ] to
nineteen and I left the house so people
don't know it's called bolita it's a
thing in New York and New Jersey where
you bet
if you bet ten dollars you would five
thousand if you bet $20 you win ten
thousand if you bet $5 you win
twenty-five hundred if you better a
dollar you went five hundred dollars and
you get paid that day you tipped a
bookmaker fifty dollars and you [ __ ]
take 450 and everybody has a party he
offered me a $10 ban I took it
I walked down up the [ __ ] hill with
my little Chinese friend Mario Diaz he
was half chinese half Cuban a bunch of
this little geeks in the neighborhood
went to karate and we got number one bus
it took us like instead of 30 minutes it
took us like I would have to get down
there but we got down there I won first
place in the forum but I'm the fighting
part now when I talk to you people are
finding no it wasn't cage fighting or
punching you some other in the face he
wasn't about that at all it was semi
contact so was from the [ __ ] neck
down to the waist
you put shields on and if you kicked
anywhere under where that shield wasn't
you either got disqualified you got a
point taken away from me
and there were three like two minutes
[ __ ] rounds that's it
there was nothing yet to get points not
trying not matter was no there was no
knockouts allowed his body kicks and
[ __ ] but we were crazy in our school he
was already teaching his [ __ ]
spinning back-kick sand all of his [ __ ]
so I think the kid had me on points in
the finals and I finally did a kick and
I kicked him on the shoulder and I got
disqualified cuz it was like that a heel
kick then I wasn't trying to hurt a kid
of nothing and I got disqualified we
shook hands afterward he even told me
was a nice kick and then I got in the
floor so I got second place and fighting
in first place and [ __ ] form and I
said that's it I'm quitting [ __ ]
karate and I got on the bus with my
little [ __ ] savages we wrote back now
I didn't get high with these guys these
karate guys did not get high and they
were by the [ __ ] book all they did
was do karate and geek out on the
weekends we would go to Chinatown and
buy karate uniforms to go to [ __ ]
Honda there was a big martial art place
called Honda that's all we did so I get
back to my house and the two trophies my
mom is proud of me I'm happy I put them
upstairs and when I come down eyeliner
goes hey [ __ ] oh oh you hit the [ __ ]
number today 219 came up you'll get your
money tomorrow
fifty five thousand dollars so I didn't
give my mother 15 off the top she shook
me down and I kept 35 and opened up an
account and heads for cause my end of my
freshman year that's how I became a drug
dealer what okay can I go back for one
second because it upset me when you said
it how do you tip the bookmaker fifty
bucks if you always tip the book I know
the bookmakers don't tell he doesn't tip
you when you lose you always took thank
you it's it's in those days that was a
protocol in fact to be honest with you
yeah he had already gotten a tip from
waiter you know anything about the
bookmaking game he really gets five
fifty from the bank
aha so he already gets it
but in our world how we do it is if you
get that money you give him a tip as a
sign of good luck
so you give another ten long I guess I
took the dealer when I'm playing at the
casino a little bit but I freaked me out
so that world was completely different
yeah so that world look when I lived in
North Bergen I was doing all the bad
should I tell you people the reason why
my friends didn't turn on me is because
every time I did something I paid them
I made them accomplices even if they had
nothing to do with nothing to do with it
there's nothing wrong with giving your
friends a hundred dollar bill make his
day that's true so if I went and robbed
a coke dealer for four grand and I got
let's say thirty eight hundred in cash
and I got an ounce of coke I would give
two or three of my buddies three hundred
cash but I knew they needed for their
mom whatever and they'd go thank you and
then two days there they find that I
robbed somebody what I gonna do [ __ ]
Coco you get they were never really
gonna rat me out they can't wrap their I
just took care of them smart and you
take that cocaine you give that around
to cook a couple people my mom wanted me
when I've got my first job she made me
give her my like first paycheck what did
your mom take the 1500 for did you say
before you or it was off the top it's
just a [ __ ] shakedown then you have
to accept okay and I accepted it there
was no arguing whether I knew my mom was
hurting for money at the time I knew she
needed she didn't have the balls to tell
me she needed oh well I knew and I just
kicked it up I was a little pissed for
to Michael either yeah I could say I
just kicked it up it took me half a day
the process the [ __ ] freshman year to
get 3,500 and I hope I took 500 off the
top I put 3,000 of the bank and I opened
up a hot account like at the bank it was
called hub or some Hudson County you
know I didn't back yet Hudson something
huh but yeah Hudson United Bank and I
put three thousand dollars and then I
kept a nickel got some nicer clothes
I got like a new basketball stupid [ __ ]
like that and then I found out that I
was paying three four hours for an acid
so I said wait a second
I had these friends first I had this
Spanish dude that his father was a
doctor and he was telling me that you're
paying for I'm paying three thought get
them from me so I started giving him the
$3.00 and I would just and I would see
that wait a second [ __ ] three dollars
what does it call I didn't know I didn't
know anything about but it was just
natural to me I had already there was a
kid in my neighborhood that would give
you a quarter pound the pot for a
hundred dollars okay that's four ounces
the water a little four ounces that's
how it's a little okay but he would give
you four ounces I did the math I'm not
[ __ ] stupid so my freshman year I'm
thinking I'm sitting that I had grown up
around drug dealers I knew the game I
knew it I swear ii if i could buy his
name was Joe and I was growing up this
guy's true I can't say his last name
because he became a cop well he was a
dear friend of mine I loved him dearly
he's the first guy that ever turned me
on to Led Zeppelin he gave me the
8-track to the song remains the same and
I nearly jumped out a [ __ ] window
but hence that's a different story so he
would give me four ounces for a hundred
hours and I would sell an ounce for $50
Wow sure I was doubling my money you
couldn't beat that all this time I've
been working for $6 an hour and all this
[ __ ] and wait a second if I sell at that
time it would sell itself like a nice
ounce for 50 bucks and I would give them
extra so I would take my house would be
a little less on my count would be a
little less I would sell it all and
double my money
it was [ __ ] like math why not we had
a double my money double my money double
my money it did I couldn't see I
couldn't hey I never lost double work
there was never I never got stuck yeah
you get stuck with a few extras
stems in those days and you have to
count that as weight so once you took
those things out it really made instead
of having 28 grams an ounce
now you got one ounce that was maybe 24
grams so I took a beat right off the top
but if I sold those at 50 bucks in game
a little extra and whatever I would
still make 70 80 dollars it wasn't a bad
[ __ ] profit for something you could
do once a day that's 400 a [ __ ] week
if we do it five times in a [ __ ] week
yeah so they turn me on and you could
have done it more yeah and I was doing
this without a car this was just to the
kids I was going to school around hey I
got no weed boom let's do it and I would
just always make money like that I
started making my like that and then
finally a friend of mine told me that he
could cop and bulk but and now at this
time I'm doing acid I'm 16 and I'm doing
a little microwave out hits acid once a
week you [ __ ] I'm trying to keep it
under the borderline I was also doing
angel dust I was doing THC crystal so I
would do that but I always was [ __ ]
out of my mind
so I'm 16 and I'm doing angel dust once
I'm Sundays I would just do it on
Sundays it was called crystal THC that
was the trick but there was elements of
angel dust in there so I would do that
how Sunday was a big track day for my
mother she would have like two of the
tracks so I know she was gonna be gone
from like 10:00 to 6:00 so I could get
high at [ __ ] 11:00 and at 6 o'clock
at least I'd be a little normal when she
got home I could at least talk to her so
I had a time my eyes are on my mother
being out cuz that last year she wasn't
really working she just had the bar but
during the week at night oh yeah I would
drop a little head ass during the week
one night and go to a friend's house and
listen to music or walk with what we
would be like David Robinson we'd walk
from here to [ __ ] Turkey and back
every night through cemeteries we just
see [ __ ] and see streaks and [ __ ] like
that
then I teamed up with this dude named
Nick and he told me about these guys in
East Stroudsburg Pennsylvania and they
were like how by now
types like they were [ __ ] that we've
had hopefully it was a whole different
world for me well is it sometimes I
think I missed out sometimes like maybe
I'm lucky at it what are you finding out
by all types in the middle incomes
Aranea there was probably I wish you to
see what their apartment looked and
smell like oh I like this place no no no
this place is a [ __ ] this place smells
great a lot of weed no they even had
weed this place my why chemicals like
anytime every time I was in them like
what is this place gonna blow up maybe
in there smoking cigarettes and [ __ ] I'm
like oh god I didn't know nothin about
nothin'
but I knew just from basic chemistry
from like myself on fire myself on fire
bro I have about two or three chemistry
sets and I'll put them together and they
create [ __ ] I haven't even know what I
was great every time we talk it explains
more and more chemical reactions [ __ ]
when I was a kid I was a I was an unholy
child and I would go to that [ __ ]
grammar school and I was surrounded with
kids for four days when I got out of
there I would go home and sit in my
attic and I just wanted to be by myself
ahead of the [ __ ] sphere and thank
God hey you know when you got comic
books in those days they always talked
about chemistry sets and I figured let
me get myself at him as he said so I
saved my pennies up and I got myself a
little cabbagey saying you know they got
like simple [ __ ] in there like sofa
yeah they add baking soda man I would
get like the except the expanded ones
where like they had like bigger ones and
had more shells and [ __ ] and they would
tell you don't combine this with this
that's the first thing it's in the Attic
I had an attic and I would twelve my
parents in there oh my god I had this
purple syrup that I made one time in the
test tube
I just kept throwing the [ __ ] in there
and I'ma putting on the carpet and the
[ __ ] carpet started like eat the way
I did so much damage at that chemistry
said I used to drink [ __ ] I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I was drinking at the
time either I was [ __ ] kidding you
play the lottery every day you're the
luckiest person alive how are you alive
I don't know I I was making [ __ ] so I
was interested until I found that then
you had to go to pharmacy school I'm
like I'm not going I just wanna learn
[ __ ] that makes it blow up and light
flies I was the king of the chemistry
set for a long time then I just quit I
just [ __ ] say that this is too much
for me I'm gonna get to absolved in the
[ __ ] involves like I clicked the
chemistry set game but when I started
meeting these dudes like I was aware
that you couldn't [ __ ] smoke in there
he couldn't do some things and you go in
then they had all those they had one
bedroom they all slept like in the
living room and both of their bedrooms
like they were college kids and both of
their bedrooms were empty it was just
manufacturing and they had like an
auntie finition and then fans and one
room had like paper when they would do
the blotter acid I mean it was like a
operate it was a mom Popeye
commemoration and I think about it now
at that time only because my buddy Nick
would take money from people and he'd go
buy it and get himself a cheaper price I
don't know what he was buying I would
buy my old stuff I was giving them in
those days nine eight hundred hours a
week and I know Nick was giving him my
900 hours a week I can't imagine how
many people were driving in to buy stuff
from them because our day was Saturday
and they ran it like a [ __ ] my
appointment like you had a half-hour and
then you had to get out of there because
then what the neighbors to see the cars
they were professional these two young
guys so wait was I'm spending a thousand
a week almost I would go up there and
spend I would I would buy 500 black
beauties
like beauties with speed there's a black
capsule and wrestlers ate them to make
weight because there were diet pills you
can't either of your speed oh so they
will call black beauties I would sell
those I would get those for 35 hours for
a thousand that would sound $4 apiece
Jesus or 35 for a hundred so I would go
back and I had five wrestlers give me so
you right off the bat I'd make a profit
and then I had 500 left to sell them $1
bills if you bought 20 I gave you 25 you
know I'm saying but after that it was
all profit yeah I didn't really matter
what they didn't really matter what I
made off it was all profit who do I give
a [ __ ] you know what do you mean 35
bucks but yeah what do I give a [ __ ] it
was a very unique business but to start
the business I had to take a thousand
dollars out of my the bank account okay
and I pretty much never touched that
bank account it was just everything
rotated out of my house after that I
think I'd made a few deposits of $200 I
think when my mom died I probably had
like $1,800 in there I never touched
that money I sustained without really a
job from April to November that year and
I would do it in such a slow like a lot
of people when they would sold ass and
every neighborhood had a different ass
of the drug representative my
neighborhood had one but we had
different clientele he wasn't in high
school okay
you could go to his house if you were in
high school I was at the school so as
soon as I walked into the school I have
20 kids already waiting for me then
we're gonna play hooky so so you buy it
a little bit of acid and I'm mostly acid
and some black beauties I would buy I
did just I just divert an acid and black
beauty's but all different types acid
every week they would make a new acid
every week they would make four-way ass
blotter acid they would make acid that
you know
was like what they do with marijuana now
it's great though I like yeah like they
would make certain strains that were
sellable something that would happen
typhoon or you know so they would all
have gimmicks they were very smart about
it they had like this acid that it was
called for away acid you could buy and
four people could do it but no we ate
the whole thing
oh and and how much would you try that
eight hundred bucks in - oh the
masculine acid the microdot was $90 for
a hundred heads sir cost me made these
cents and I was selling for three
dollars so I wouldn't make a two dollar
and ten dollar profit on each one I
would pick up a thousand dollars a week
and probably sell 200 sub guys that
weren't gonna go in competition with me
like let's say somebody lived on in the
Kennedy School District I would give
solve that Mahajan and let's say
somebody lived on 64th streets field I
would give them 143rd Street 46th Street
38th Street Park I was a substation you
were never scared but the cops finding
out about heinous no because even if
they found out I had it out how do you
went out I had caught my balls and oh I
always had it out there was always and I
was doing it in such a small level that
nobody would have known ie thank God and
that nobody ever died yeah oh yeah I
didn't have anybody who was careless
you know those hits of microd not
thinking back on them they were harmless
okay we're a lot stronger than the acid
you and I have done here you have done
you and I have done acid maybe three
times and all three times we've done it
in the micro level in a very that's
Michael yeah oh my god and for me it's
been like a it's like a three-hour I've
never gone into the other side like I
used to when I was a kid where's the
other side feeling the other side is
like
you just learned another side I feel
like I was there too now to buy the
experience every now we walk we stop you
trip more we walk we stop by your house
you tell me you're freaking that kind
that we smoke some more pot we calm you
down and then we'd walk we'd walk we
walk and then you feel yourself coming
down you start yawning but there were
all lies those are all signals your body
tells you to think that it's done and
it's no use knowing it keeps going you
know how many times I went in because
I'm I'm coming down and next thing you
know I'm sitting in bed I'm saying
[ __ ] the posters spinning around my
stomach is feeling nauseous just
thinking about it sit
trust me when you're doing it and you're
having fun there's no more fondant oh no
III I could you know I tell jokes on
stage that my dog is not gonna have the
fun I had grown up I'm very appreciative
of what happened my situation a lot of
times yeah I lost a mother but I got a
gift out of people and now I know how to
give back and that's that gift of you
know I have a handle some money like the
kid that I hadn't here a couple of weeks
ago we came in here he's his his
daughter hangs out with my daughter and
he's a great guy his wife's a great lady
I brought him back here with us at
Aerosmith I was telling you guys the
other day the reason why I took him back
here was because his mom and died his
mom and dad had died in a matter of two
months and he was going through some
heavy stuff and when you go through that
it makes everything else seem heavier
and it's so weird that I lost my mom at
16 and I see people who lost their jobs
who lost their moms now and I still get
[ __ ] emotional when they tell me still
bothers me to an extent that Jesus
Christ that happened to me so long ago
and I still feel so much pain
how could you not and I can't imagine to
go over again well I went through those
first three years I wouldn't wish that
on anybody you know and I can't and it
takes its toll at every age don't get me
wrong it hurts in every age losing the
motherhood so every AIDS
there's people talk about losing it
listen losing a [ __ ] father at any
age hurts
I should just focus on the mothers
losing friends losing losing a friend
you know it affected me Ralph remains
death has affected me till this day guys
like when I was a kid Anthony balsamo's
death affected me and then my mother's
death affected me my father's death
affected me my uh Dominick specialis
death affected me for a while that that
that destroyed me at that age and then I
lived a few years and you meet more
people you lose along the way and then
you know I lost Marilyn that was
devastating that was 11 years ago and
then Ralphie made me make a change when
somebody's death makes you get up and go
oh I [ __ ] get this now that's an
every death I've done that I've learned
from somebody's death when Richard Jeni
shot himself God rest his soul when
Mitch Hedberg died god rest his soul
they were all different circumstances
but a part of me felt some things I had
to change something on some situations I
didn't you know with Marilyn and made me
take a colonoscopy more often to make
them think make them put a finger of my
ass
more often from time to time but with
you know with every Ralphie's death I
gotta tell you something in the church
family sees this when we put that video
up in December Lee and I learned
something from Ralphie that he's still
alive I mean you guys downloaded 300
thousand times and it's that's better
than a regular [ __ ] guest and you guys
all responded to it so if you imagine if
you guys responded
that type of manner how it affected me I
think about Ralphie when I set my
schedule up now you know a lot of people
lately have been hit me up a little hey
man you haven't been doing the [ __ ]
the morning joints a little more you
know why you know why I was yesterday I
was on a [ __ ] field trip I was on a
field trip with kids you know it's I'm
not it it's coming to a place now that
life is unwinding and I can't do the
crazy [ __ ] I was doing and while plus
we'll never leaves not here the
periscope don't work so I said this
times I come here two times they've come
in so far
to do the [ __ ] periscope and it won't
work unless you're here I guarantee you
now it works now we could do it but no
it's not that I forgot about you guys in
any way shape or form it's that life has
really got into the way if I don't go
this days I gotta meet with the [ __ ]
riot is it [ __ ] ten o'clock I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm doing I have no
idea what I'm doing I'm gonna [ __ ] do
you guys think I'm a [ __ ] writer you
vary my material it's [ __ ] stupid
stories to show right then no I gotta go
[ __ ] right I don't know what I'm
[ __ ] doing see the periscope isn't
working in here no more
maybe the periscope thing have to throw
off the test with Instagrammer you
another thing but it's not that I don't
love you guys if by no means is that
wife has really gotten to the way the
last couple [ __ ] but it's real but
you you have a choice what you're saying
is is like older Joey Diaz like you have
a choice you could still do the morning
joint and be like I don't want to go on
this field trip but because of the way
Ralphie's death death affected you you
you're making different choices
absolutely absolutely I'm making
different choices of how eighth I'm
making different choices on how to take
cam myself last time we're at the at the
Comedy Store and I was speaking from
comic and he goes you know I'm just
happy to be home rock the road and this
and that and he goes I gotta take a
break and I go you know man
that Club is gonna be there next year
and it was like I said something that
the Lord would have said he looked at me
like I had said some things I never
thought about it that way he does but
then these agents call you and they said
that the or they don't make offers all
they want they can make all the offers
all they want the club is gonna be there
next year I want to go there and give me
the best possible [ __ ] show I could
give you I don't want to go to a [ __ ]
City and chuck and jive when you don't
see rogue and touring I'll tell you it's
cuz he don't have the [ __ ] you don't
want to cover the spread he doesn't have
the material to cover the spread
sometimes it's the same thing with us we
want to be the best we can be when I go
out there when I go out there I want to
give you the best before that's why
Clinton Cronin hit me up this morning a
great guy up in San Jose you know would
you do the podcast I when I go on the
road it's still [ __ ] right and do
come that's all I want to focus on I'm
gonna do a couple workouts I'm gonna go
to original Joe's and eat with Yaga
steno but besides that I've already seen
San Jose 80 [ __ ] times I don't want
to see nothing I just want to focus on
you guys I'm getting older you know I go
to the store on Tuesdays Thursdays and
Saturdays when I'm in town listen if you
know anything about the Comedy Store
the electricity the the magic you want
to be down there every night I can't
cover the [ __ ] spread like I told you
guys a week ago ever since I watched
that Rogan podcast with the sleep guy
I've been long and on my sleep I'd do
everything I try to because I understand
how important it is 20 years ago it
wasn't important to me and look what the
result was look at me in the longest
shot looking at my head's about to
[ __ ] explode I'm trying to live here
for this little girl and I'm trying to
be the best dad I could beat her right
now and mixing it in with Tom Lee
podcasting writing a book jesus [ __ ]
christ but anyway back to the original
subject empathy is my heart goes out to
Jerry Rocha and the road he has to deal
with my light's gone out to a lot of my
friends the last couple years
a lot of my friends of lost people and
listen man the good thing about I think
the good thing about the way we do our
Facebook and my Twitter and you guys
have noticed it if you guys are [ __ ]
listen there's a thing called the DM and
there's a way to be a gentleman
you thinking about something you don't
want to [ __ ] talk to somebody about it
somebody died or something listen we
live across the street from a funeral
parlor and all about that the reactions
to it you guys know when I went through
with Demi and Mary two months ago with
the two cats going within a month I I
know how to grieve it you know I told
you I'm writing this book this is
chapter I have to do about the
kidnapping I could not do the kidnapping
without not letting me know the
evolutions of drugs in my life and what
they did you know yesterday I was eating
dinner and they said that they gave
they'll chop all life I was just
watching the news listening to a news on
the side and I'm thinking to myself you
know what a he deserves more than a
[ __ ] life and even though I did coke
for 2,000 years and I was the main
contributor to it these guys were in on
shipping poisoning to America I got
three friends I grew up with down and a
half [ __ ] cocked in their 50s because
of what we went through in our [ __ ]
80s with these drugs they deserve to get
what they get but anyway we made our own
choices I'm not blaming ol chapo or his
cousin anybody else for doing the
mistakes I did
the point being is that we did what the
[ __ ] we did no we got to deal with it
now we get older and I can't now two
main thing that comes to my mind that I
wanted to do a single podcast with you
guys let you know i can't believe i'm
turning 56 i cannot believe i'm turning
56 all those years walking around and
writing [ __ ] down and you know having
these semi dreams about things
I never once I called my friend didi the
other day and I said didi
all those years you and I walked around
together and talked at the age of 16 15
that we haven't talked about your 50s
nobody ever talks about their 50s nobody
ever says wow when I'm [ __ ] 15 nobody
it because we don't [ __ ] think about I
never thought I would make it the
[ __ ] 50 I'm sitting on Tuesday and
I'm gonna be 50 [ __ ] 6 years old how
[ __ ] fast did this go last birthday
remember is you know coming home my mom
telling me I hit the number and that's
how fast i won
that's how fat like much land as she was
[ __ ] god god that was my last
birthday with my 17th birthday I
celebrated in the Attic I broke into my
mother's house with 18 euros and we had
the party of the year up in that attic
everybody puked like six people were
puking at once the [ __ ] in the house was
a mess sounds great my father locked up
the house after that alarm and there we
could not get in it was [ __ ] horrible
I'm just saying
just for the record man that uh you know
like I said if you're going through
something and I mean you know don't
[ __ ] hit me that you want to be on
the [ __ ] podcast if somebody dies a
cat a dog a dad the end me let's talk
about it
let's talk how to put it in perspective
before it eats away on you you know what
was one of the biggest skeletons in my
closet not dealing with my mother's
death I swear to you guys I swear to you
guys my mom died in 79 and I didn't deal
with it till 85 I threw everything I
could of dealing with it the pushing is
far away from me as I could I threw
rocks on it I did heroin I did coke I
drank I did pills I did everything that
good not to deal with a debt and it
backfired on being in 1984 I ended up
homeless [ __ ] you know grind it grind
it mentally
why because I didn't deal with it listen
I don't say there's a thousand times I
do not believe you give them somebody
induce a week to talk to somebody about
this stuff this is stuff that you talk
to with your friend we all have a friend
who has a parent that passed away give
him a call how do they deal with it
everybody deal is a little [ __ ]
differently you know I noticed a friend
of mine always tells me his dad taught
him how to box and sometimes this guy
goes in and out because he still mourns
his dad his dad's been gone for about a
year and a half great guy
lean though is a great guy yeah that was
hitting the back of this joint and I saw
him standing I got hey man do me a favor
teach me some of the stuff your dad
taught me and he looked at me like a
ghost hitter and I did that for a reason
because I know he's dealing with it and
we got to the fight position meet him
Saturday and I was throwing faint jabs
and he was hitting my gloves he was
showing me all this [ __ ] his dad taught
him when he was growing up his dad was a
real boxer and he was teaching me how a
jab jab jab and you had him with a hook
and they don't see it coming and he
taught me a counter off the right
[ __ ] cross and and as I was looking
at him he was telling me all this with a
smile on his face and I game while your
dad taught you some good stuff and he
looked at me kind of like you [ __ ]
played me [ __ ] it's not that they
said I know what people are dealing with
when they lose a loved one you know my
friend Timmy I can feel it when I talk
to him on the phone he lost his mom and
his dad you know his life has been a run
this is what happens you lose your
compass
don't let it get there if you lose
somebody don't let it get to you just
lose your compass sit down call your
friends that have gone through a similar
situation and those people are gonna be
your anchor trust me those people are
gonna keep you [ __ ] together it's not
some psychiatrist
it's not some [ __ ] pills listen you
might we all need to self medicate
don't ever get me wrong you know I love
the gift of grief
because grief grieving I'm sorry
grieving after you lose somebody happens
just like this you wake up in the
morning you think about that person for
a second or two and then the day
overtakes your mind of what things you
have to do that day and then you do all
those things you go to all these parties
you go all these events you go to see
with your friends you get your car at
the end then I know you bruh you head
home and that pain creeps up on it it
doesn't show up so maybe a half hour
before you're gonna go to bed and that's
what you got to deal with that pain
because some people around you that pain
goes away you forget all about that pain
it's something you get home at night
then you really gotta confront that
demon that's why he is I would go home
to party I would go home and I would go
[ __ ] confronting that demon because it
doesn't hit you in the daytime when
you're active that's why I tell people
right for somebody passes you got about
a week to put it into perspective and
then it'll even take oh it'll take over
you or you have to take over it so the
best thing is to stay busy and surround
yourself with people people constantly
in and out and do this way yourself then
at night you're gonna have to answer to
the pipe and that's what all the
problems fall on your shoulders that's
why most people go home and what do they
do they smoke or drink they have a drink
because this is what the demons catch up
to you and they [ __ ] knock you on the
shoulder and go hey we didn't know wait
what I would do is numb it I would
[ __ ] get high put on Black Sabbath
and pass out crying where I should have
got up I was too young and wrote about
it what I'm feeling I mean I'm the
[ __ ] kid that after my mother died
two years later I would still go to the
house to see if they made a mistake you
know so please if you're grieving
there's a process
and I basically did this show for Gerry
Rocha cuz he's travelling and he said is
gonna download it you know and there's a
process to grieving and forty years
later I can tell you it still hurts it
doesn't hurt as much but it still
[ __ ] plays with my legs from time to
time I could still itching the stomach
and you know somebody's gone and that's
it that's that man it's [ __ ]
Valentine's Day baby and this was just a
solo podcast today just to keep you
[ __ ] alive and let you know I
didn't forget about you even though
things are happening that busy we got a
church family member that's down
top-quality Tony our hearts and prayers
go out to him you know he's he came to a
bunch of Vegas shows and I know they're
talking to Michael Klein and they've
been going back and forth we retrieve
their picture if you want do me a favor
to send them your your thoughts and your
prayers I've been [ __ ] San Jose and
there's not much I could do up in here
but do [ __ ] six shows I want to thank
you for selling out all six shows the
church family coming in [ __ ] strong I
got no military I got an old man I'm
just planning and smoking dope and
having a good [ __ ] time no edibles
I'm back off the edible train but I
gotta be honest here I got a box of CBD
edibles in the [ __ ] mail two days ago
and I finally looked at them yesterday
I'm gonna tell you more about these
[ __ ] things they were tremendous I
heard I can't like I had a pup I popped
a couple [ __ ] cubes last night before
I was asleep
I got up one time to pee at three and
the other time was 748 when my daughter
was shaking me going dad I'm leaving and
I got up gave her a kiss
talked gonna let nobody [ __ ] with you
today and I see a four o'clock before
[ __ ] karate and [ __ ] and I got up
like nothing I went and got coffee
usually my everything hurts I feel like
I got hit by a train so I'm gonna keep
you aware that's 10 good [ __ ] company
I like my CBDs dog I rub them by my
knees if I take a shower as soon as I
get out of shower I rub CBD oil this
super-strength [ __ ] they got up here on
my knees my shoulders I rub it on my
hands I worked two Chinese balls which a
lot of women should be working at each
Jonathan juggle balls I had a guy in New
York that gave me a box in the Chinese
box and has those two balls in it two
Chinese handball and when you spin them
it plays Chinese song for you this is
tremendous for the fingers interesting
morning Gary doctor you got to make the
best you'd think I want for the grave on
a banana peel you know I'm saying yes I
appreciate every [ __ ] day
cuz I don't [ __ ] know I don't [ __ ]
know no you're right you're it and I I
don't want to harp on it too much
because I think you're right and and
something that I've definitely learned
from you is to be better with your
friends but I'm someone who has trouble
even like I don't even think I have too
many close friends I have always been
someone I'd like a couple but not a
bunch but sometimes I have trouble
opening up um I have enjoyed going and
talking with somebody so if I I just
know there's some people out there
listening who might be like I don't have
anyone to call I think they might feel
like that so and and you are writing
better to help you were I up or any of
that but III I think therapy has a place
if because some people don't have it as
as much as I I have people in my life
and sometimes you know we don't want to
say please some people well a lot of
times you don't even think of those
things when you're talking to people
sometimes a psychiatrist has a way of
getting it out of you oh yeah also
helpful a lot of people that have a hard
time spilling their guts of
psychiatrists they're professionals they
know how to get it out of here
in a certain way you know I'm not saying
what I'm saying works for everybody what
I'm saying was at the time when I was
suffering through what I was going
through first of all they know
psychiatry was really available to me
and even if it was available to me I'm
paying you what cocaine could do a
better job I woulda listened
that was from time to time I tell myself
it's time to go start talking to
somebody I just don't have the balls and
when I do go through something that's
that deep I have four guys I call and I
get their opinion some stuff I could ask
my wife about some stuff I know she's
gonna go into a tirade about it but you
know what I asked my friends a lot of
[ __ ]
that was your friend that that's just
saying it helps I have four different
voices five or six different voices and
if I don't know the [ __ ] answer to
the questions I ask questions
I'm not true Barris to ask a question I
don't know everything
so I want to know everything this time
is I got a question for Rogan
there's things that Rogan don't
understand there's times I got a
question for my friend James this times
I asked Timmy this times I talked I
talked a lot to George because we
enjoyed said similar lifestyles probably
talking a lot to George you know this
times I'm say who else is good Felicia
how call Felicia Felicia is really good
on attack mode sometimes then you go
Jesus Christ you know Felicia did this
but she had enough so I have that
community of people Ari Ari's great Ari
is level-headed and guess what we work
off each other i re a lot about where
he's slipping with a G's that how fast
this goes this goes fast this goes
faster than what you anticipate two
weeks ago was Christmas two weeks ago
was Christmas I don't know how you guys
feel but in my world it was Christmas
two [ __ ] weeks ago so you know I'm
[ __ ] still confused and we're going
on Valentine's Day
it was just [ __ ] Christmas two weeks
ago I ain't getting no [ __ ] younger
neither are you [ __ ] guys so listen
yeah talk to somebody if you're feeling
down I just wanted to do this podcast to
let people know man that we all going
through a [ __ ] you know we all go
through [ __ ] and you have avenues I said
no this a lot of people red band was
going to come on this week and talk
about the amount of people around us
that are basically losing their minds
you're watching it you're seeing it on
social media people that you were
friends with whether it's political
motivations whether it's you know you're
watching I just found out about this
Alex Jones think it's it's it's
unbelievable and it's scary it scares
you in a way that
people lose their minds I hope you
people see that we have gotten better
we're trying not to lose our minds we've
cut down on the edibles we've cut down a
lot of things we've taken care of
ourselves I got to applaud we he has
been going that little sitting this
thing on Tuesday and Thursdays it's a
start it starts somewhere little
commitments become big commitments
I gotta applaud you for that lately you
have been showing up even when he was
out of town you haven't been coming up
with excuses lately you haven't been
making a false appointments at one
o'clock that you have to take when you
know that you you got all day to take
them and you've been gone and you've
been working through it yes I have
gorgeous thank you because that's what
it's all about I think Lee has a
misconception sometimes that you do
something for three months and that's it
no it's every week and different life is
it's every week it's the same [ __ ]
record life gets boring but if it's
working why [ __ ] fix it life gets
boring you're gonna have to do a
thousand things over and over and over
and over and over just to get to where
you need to be that's what it is people
work out four times a week and people
have the luxury that I had like to get
up in the morning and stroll into a gym
at 9:00
they're people that take my [ __ ]
hearts out there that things work a
[ __ ] eight-hour day and then they go
to a [ __ ] gym my heart goes out to
you I give you all the utmost respect I
go to a gym at seven o'clock I don't
even know where to start
they're talking about throwing left I'm
throwing right I'm throwing knees I'm I
don't know nothing by seven o'clock I'm
fried all I'm good for is [ __ ] timely
or even being at the gym and she's gonna
be in the gym at six no more those guys
that go at six and that Joey Alvarado he
puts up a [ __ ] video every Monday
Wednesday and Friday
and I see nine people at 5:30 in the
morning doing burpees and swings
kettlebell swings you think I goof on
those people I [ __ ] put someone that
thing every [ __ ] day every day I
couldn't imagine doing
I could go to box at eight o'clock I can
catch a 9:00 a.m. Muay Thai class but
anything else that is the way as the day
progresses
you're gonna catch a shitty [ __ ] Joey
Diaz just the way it is it's the law of
diminishing returns I'm 56 I'm a lot
better in the morning than I am at
[ __ ] night by night I'm I'm I'm
cooked
1 - [ __ ] cooked so I don't know how to
[ __ ] you feel it's Valentine's Day
[ __ ] go out there have a good [ __ ]
date today send somebody all right send
somebody you love just tell them you
love maybe they're going through
something they're single call them up
say happy Valentine's Day
I'm gonna shoot an arrow in your [ __ ]
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] you need whatever
the [ __ ] you need is a little cheer up
that's what we're all about
listen it was a great [ __ ] week I
hope you have a great week next week
we're getting down I'm sorry about
Sunday's podcast with Steve Simone a lot
of people want to hear what Steve Simone
have to say we'll get them back on here
we just had an accident that would never
happen again trust me it'll never happen
again
Cleveland I don't know [ __ ] the [ __ ] up
I don't ever want to be in that position
again how [ __ ] up I was on Sunday
night don't forget thank you again for
selling out the Improv this weekend in
San Jose and next week we're coming in
heavy into [ __ ] Vegas
Friday me and Kate Quigley at Treasure
Island and then Saturday at the Fox
Theater and [ __ ] cool sound
we're coming in heavy happy I don't give
a [ __ ] about the State Fair in Tucson or
the rodeo give you tickets back [ __ ]
uncle Joey's coming to town and it's
only Arizona parents this [ __ ] year I
gotta save on the [ __ ] weeks I burnt
myself out last year I hope you
understand second of all I want to thank
our sponsors as usual for keeping this
ship a [ __ ] sale not to mention you
savage [ __ ] but anyway I'm
talking about jobs listen to me you know
how hard it is to hire the right people
to find the right qualified candidates
it takes a long time you gotta go
through applications you gotta go
through applicants and background checks
listen zip recruiter makes all this nice
and easy all right zip recruiter calm is
the slash Church is the way to go
hiring used to be hard multiple job site
stacks of resumes a confusing review
positive but today hiring can be easy
and you only have to go to one place to
get it done zip recruiter com
zip recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading with job
boards but they don't stop there with
their powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and invites them listen to me and
invites them to apply for your job as
the application comes in the zip
recruiter analyzes each one and spots
like the top candidates so you never
miss a great match the zip recruiter is
so effective that 80% of its employers
who post on zip recruiter I've got a
quality candidate through the site
within the first day you can't beat that
and right now the church family can get
zip recruiter for free our lessness
for free at sip recruited comm slash
church again that's zipper crew Netcom
slash church like I said hiring is a
challenge but there's one place you
could go to make it simple the place is
zip recruiter comm slash Church CH you
are CH and you're gonna let you try it
for free I'm Uncle Joe alright number
two I want to thank our main but listen
since day one on it's been there for me
you know what I live off their
supplements whether it's some Mexican
chocolate protein powder they got those
new boxes with the one-a-day vitamins in
them I went through them already I gotta
get another order it's just been lazy
I'm very content with just getting the
alpha brain from them and the shroom
techs boughten immune to keep me alive
in the gym if I was you I give them all
a try gonna calm right now right now
look at that tremendous supplements I
can't do none fear with the weighted
vest and I can't not do nothing fear
what the other thing but as far as
supplements I got your mother [ __ ]
10% off delivered right to your door
what do I recommend number one alpha
brain number two shroom tech sports room
tech immune they got the MCT oil they
got so many they got the beef jerky they
did they did the elk jerky you know they
got the [ __ ] coconut loves protein
bar listen gonna holla calm right now
look at that great line of supplements
when you find something you want go to
the box impress
Church BAM and get 10 [ __ ]
percent off your honor all right listen
I love you guys
have a happy Valentine's Day with you
you're single you know you're not alone
you got your uncle Joey whether you're
single whether you together have a happy
Valentine's Day
love the one you're with and that's it
[ __ ] have a great week and I'll
see you back here on [ __ ] President's
Day take this [ __ ] meal way